[Music]
good morning everyone welcome and thanks
for joining us today
my name is Adrian McNeil and I'm a
director of engineering at cruise
automation so that cruise I lead our
engineering productivity team and so
we're responsible for building tools and
infrastructure that supports the unique
development workflows of building a
self-driving car if you're not familiar
with cruise where a self-driving car
startup here in San Francisco so we're
backed by General Motors
we have also raised around five billion
dollars in additional funding from
Softbank and Honda and our mission is to
launch a fully driverless car so if
you're a passenger in one of our cars
there's no need for you to be
responsible for other driving at all
you're gonna you know you don't need to
pay attention to the road you can sit
bag you can eat you can read a book
watch a movie get some work done or
sleep if you want and our vehicles are
powered by a wide variety of sensors so
we have cameras light ours several
different types of radars
and also some powerful onboard computer
and our car needs to use all of these
sensors - first of all it needs to make
a 3d model of the world so it needs to
understand its its environment
the second thing is it needs to make a
plan for how it wants to navigate
through this environment and finally it
needs to turn this plan into steering
braking acceleration commands so this is
the control stack we're currently
testing our vehicles here on the streets
of San Francisco and probably one of the
best perks about working for cruises
that we have this mobile app the
employees can use to request rides and
self-driving cars anywhere in the city
and testing in this complex urban
environment provides really interesting
incredibly rich data that our cars and
our engineers can learn from what really
excites me at Cruise is getting to work
on tools and infrastructure that support
the unique development workflows of our
self-driving cars so this actually is an
example of one of our internal tools
called Weber's and it's a 3d web-based
visuals
until that allows our engineers to
understand any of our driving since the
data see exactly what the car was
thinking or seeing or doing at any point
in time there's different panels that
they can turn on and off and different
overlays to understand the internals of
the AV stack this talk is specifically
about our simulation at cruise and
simulation is incredibly important for
building a self-driving car it's one of
the most important pillars and it's also
a super interesting challenge so first
of all I'm going to talk a bit about
what I mean by simulation for
self-driving cars and why that's
important and then we're going to talk
about the infrastructure that allows us
to run all of these simulations at scale
and finally I'm going to talk about the
data pipeline and analytics that allow
us to understand all of this data that
we get from our simulations so first of
all why is simulation important as I
mentioned we test our our cars on the
streets of San Francisco and it's a
super challenging environment we
encounter pedestrians and cyclists
motorbikes double parked cars emergency
vehicles construction zones far more
frequently than we would if we were
testing our cars or when we test our
cars and more suburban environments and
I'm going to talk a bit more about this
photo in a minute but first of all I
want to show you a couple of examples of
the types of situations that we run into
in a daily basis driving in San
Francisco
so the way our cars are able to learn so
quickly is that we do things like this
we take them in San Francisco into the
middle of a school zone at rush hour and
this is the kind of situation that's
difficult even for a human to navigate
so it gives us incredibly useful data
about not only how our cars behave in
the situation but also you know this is
this is data that we can train from and
learn from we run into construction
zones pretty frequently so account needs
to grow to handle a sort of dynamically
changing city environment
double parked cars a you know a very
frequent occurrence in San Francisco
even moving double parked cars in this
case and I guess you can't see here but
we're actually stopping for a yeah and
sometimes when we're getting around
double parked cars we need to go into
oncoming traffic and we also need to
understand when people are yielding for
us and sort of expecting us to go and
these are all things that we go through
fully autonomously finally when we're
making unprotected left turns we need to
know how to look for a gap in traffic
and how to clear an intersection so in
the early days of cruise our development
workflow mostly consisted of taking an
example like this one of these scenarios
and maybe something where we thought we
could have done a better job at one of
our engineers would download this to
their computer they would be able to run
through it locally maybe make some code
changes or introduced a new ml model and
then they would run it through the the
CI and unit tests and once they thought
that you know that was successful they
were deployed on the road and we would
do that together
additional data about how that code is
performing in production but you know
this is a pretty inefficient workflow
for two reasons
first of all it takes a really long time
to get feedback to our engineers if
every time we want to know how our
driving is improving we need to go out
deploy it to a car drive around the road
and just sort of hope we run into more
challenging situations like this the
second thing is I guess most importantly
if an engineer is only working on a
single scenario locally and they make
changes to that code they may have made
that one scenario significantly better
but they don't know if they've made
three other scenarios slightly worse so
it's really important that our our
engineers can test their code across a
wide variety at variety of scenarios and
sort of understand how our behavior is
I'll give you one more example so this
is us starts with us making unprotected
left turn we've got pedestrians that we
need a year or two and look for a gap
and then we come across a construction
zone and we need to identify that this
construction worker here is holding up
the stop sign that he's expecting us to
wait and then once he sort of starts
waving us on the car needs to navigate
through the scene and also needs to
check that you know it's safe to cross
these double yellow lines and check that
you know we're not worried about that
other guys sort of running out in front
of us why is he standing on the road and
this is another example of why
simulation is really important though
because while we run into we come across
construction zones every day in San
Francisco no two construction zones are
the same and it's really important that
we can understand not only how our car
behaves in scenarios that we have seen
but also ones that we haven't seen and
so with simulation we can take something
like this and we can ask questions like
what would have happened if we what if
this human was standing more further out
into the road what if the cones were in
a different place what if the
construction equipment was in a
different place so we can take one of
these scenarios and we can create many
potentially hundreds or thousands of
variations on it so why is the
simulation important it allows us to
validate our driving behavior across a
large database of different simular
different examples before we go driving
on the road we get a faster feedback
cycle for our engineers and we can
understand how our behavior changes as
we vary one of those scenarios I'm going
to talk a little bit more about that
later so this brings us back to the
intersection with the cable car this
photo was not actually taken in San
Francisco this is from our simulated
driving environment known and generally
as the matrix and just like the just
like the matrix the car has no idea that
it's inside so we are simulating
everything from the camera and lidar
inputs using ray tracing and
the car goes through its normal process
of doing perception and planning
controls and responding with steering
and braking commands and testing in a
simulated environment like this allows
us to reliably reproduce weird edge
cases and scenarios that we haven't seen
in the real world in a simulated
environment like this we can control
everything pedestrians cars cable cars
even other cruise cars and so simulation
like this is one of the most important
pillars of self-driving car development
got a bit of work to do on our
pedestrians walking
and this is so this is just one type of
example of simulation so this is what's
known as an end to end simulation where
we're simulating everything from our
sensor input through to the steering and
braking commands but there's many other
different types of simulations so
another example is a replay test where
we're taking actual sensor data that
we've recorded from the real world
playing that back against the car stack
and then we can compare the results of
this to our steering and we can compare
the results of what we detected to the
human labeled ground truth data and that
allows us to score how well the car did
it tuning that sensor input into an
accurate 3d model of its environment
another example was a planning
simulation so in a planning simulation
we can construct an example like an
intersection here we have some
pedestrians entering a crosswalk the
cars trying to make a left turn and we
can create an assertion such as that the
car must yield to these pedestrians and
the key difference with this type of
simulation is that we're not simulating
sensor input here we're simply giving
the car an on state of the world and
then we're validating its behavior and
this is much cheaper to run if we want
to do hundreds or thousands of
variations this is not an exhaustive
list there's many other different types
of tests and simulations we run so for
example we also do a lot of performance
testing where we're running our car
stack against real car computer hardware
and that way we can benchmark things
like latency CPU memory GPU use so we
have a huge number of these different
scenarios every one of these scenarios
we might want to create hundreds or
potentially thousands of different
variations each of these these tests
that we run requires large runtime
assets so sometimes you might be using
over 100 gigs of data that needs to be
copied onto that worker and that's
things like binary assets map tiles ml
models recorded sensor data and finally
these tests produce really detailed
metrics and data so a self-driving car
simulation is much more than just a
pass/fail result just like driving well
on the road as much more than just not
crashing or just following the road
rules so our engineers really need to
understand
exactly how our car behaves in that
simulation it's critical that we pair
the simulation with on-road driving for
a couple reasons first of all we want to
do on-road driving so that we can find
new and unique situations and the second
one is we need to validate that our
simulations accurately reflect the types
of things that we're observing in the
real world so by combining this on-road
driving and complex urban environments
with the simulation maximizes the result
that the the rate at which our cars can
learn so that gives you a sort of a
brief understanding of what simulation
means and why it's important next I'm
going to talk about the infrastructure
that allows us to run these simulations
at scale testing infrastructure aircrews
is running at massive scale so every day
we're running over 200 thousand hours of
simulations we do this on a cluster of
30,000 instances with 5,000 GPUs and you
can think about this as 30,000 virtual
cars driving around every day
to validate our cars behavior and just
to put that number in perspective Cruise
has around 180 test vehicles registered
with the state of California so we're
running over a hundred times more cars
in simulation than we do in the real
world we also produced nearly a third of
a petabyte of day of results from all of
these simulations if you ask me a year
ago whether I thought we were running
large-scale test infrastructure at Cruz
I would have said absolutely but the use
of simulation at Cruz is rapidly
expanding as our engineers find new and
unique ways to benefit from this from
these simulations and so our test
infrastructure and the number of hours
of compute that we've been running has
grown by over 25 times in the past 12
months alone so you can imagine this
provides some pretty interesting scaling
challenges so we have really record
scheduling if jobs sometimes you know
jobs this changing state over a thousand
times per second we need to deal with
CPU GPU resource availability make sure
we have quotas to support our demand we
need to balance our utilization and make
sure that you know we don't have too
many workers sitting idle or that we
don't have jobs queuing we need to
distribute these job inputs
100 gigabytes of data needs to
efficiently be moved to potentially
thousands of machines quickly and
efficiently and finally we need a data
pipeline that allows us to make sense of
all of this data that we generate from
the simulations we choose to run this in
Google Cloud because it allows us to
scale much faster than we can on our own
physical infrastructure so we do have
some on frame hardware that we use for
testing on real car computer hardware as
I mentioned that's great for performance
benchmarking but the vast majority of
our computer runs in Google Cloud one of
the other main advantages is that Google
supports these custom machine worker
types so we can choose exactly how many
GPUs how many CPU cores and how much RAM
we want for an instance and this is
really valuable when we're running
different kinds of simulations we get
access to the latest generation GPUs and
hardware and this is really beneficial
for the productivity of our engineers
and we're able to use the best-in-class
managed services so we take advantage of
spinnaker pub/sub bigquery and Google
Cloud Storage I guess - before we talk
about our current architecture it's
helpful to think about where we've come
from so in 2016
Cruz was a pretty small company when it
was acquired originally it was about 40
employees and we treated simulation as
fundamentally part of CI so we had a CI
system that launched VMs and containers
and the CI system had a homogeneous
worker pool so we had to run all of our
builds and tests on expensive GPU
instances we were also limited to 16
times parallelization and that was due
to some performance bottlenecks in the
system so ultimately this resulted in
engineers spending a lot of time waiting
for simulations to run we solved this by
introducing a new tool called Hydra and
Hydra is a job scheduler so it's called
by CI or useless requesting a job
consists of a master and then various
worker pools and it can send jobs to
these worker poles on the worker we use
docker to execute the job and on the GPU
workers we're using Nvidia docker to
provide access to that hardware the
Hydra master writes all of its job state
and and kind of results of these
simulations into the Postgres database
and then as often happens at early-stage
companies we
up with a whole bunch of dashboards and
reporting tools which were talking
directly to that database as our load
increased though it became play that
this architecture was not going to scale
very well so they were performance
bottlenecks especially in the database
with locking and triggers and it was
play that we needed to revise this for
anyone who's made change to a production
system before though you'll know that
it's it's much easier said than done so
any API that can be depended on would
probably be depended on somewhere and we
had things like various reporting tools
that were talking directly to these
databases we had triggers that we didn't
want to interrupt we wanted to switch
over to the new system without any
downtime and we wanted to keep the work
or API backwards compatible so at the
start of this year we migrated to our
new architecture and Hydra to is a
collection of individually scalable
components so we completely rewrote the
hydro master and go and that manages the
scheduling and it talks via the exact
same API backwards-compatible API to our
workers the scheduler has its own
database so it's using cloud spanner to
track all of the current in progress job
state and then from there we replicate
the job execution history first of all
back to the reporting database that the
tools were depending on and then also
through pubs up to bigquery which is a
much more scalable data warehouse Hydra
2 was built to take advantage of all of
their building blocks that we have
available to us in GCP so we're using
things like cloud load balancing
kubernetes Engine and cloud spanner to
run the master we're using container
registry and cloud storage for storing
our inputs we have put data going into
cloud storage and then we're also using
pub/sub and bigquery to manage our
output data and our execution logs I'm
going to talk through each of these
components but we're gonna start with
the most interesting one which is the
worker pools so a worker pools are made
up of tens of thousands of instances and
our goal here is basically to recreate
this an entire room of servers that are
running for our benefit from the comfort
of our laptop we do this using Google
compute engine which is great product it
allows us to spin up a VM on demand and
as I mentioned one of the great features
about compute engine is that we can
choose exactly what race
a GPU CPU and RAM that we want we're not
limited to these kind of predefined
instance sizes and so computer engine
has a feature called managed instance
groups and this is similar to auto
scaling groups in AWS and this allows
you to create a template instance and
then you can scale up or down many many
hundreds of instances of the exact same
sized managed instance groups come in
two flavors so there's regional
management since groups and these are
tied to a specific region such as URIs
waste and they automatically scale up
instances and balance them across all of
the zones so in this example we have us
waste is our region there's an instance
group in it and then we're creating all
of the instances in the three zones and
URIs West unfortunately when you use
regional management since groups it's
it's very aggressive but making sure
that you have balance of the number of
instances across the different zones so
this is primarily designed for high
availability workloads if you're serving
customer traffic you you want to have
spare capacity and make sure that you
know for quests are coming in you don't
end up dropping one just because the
zone went down but for batch workloads
we don't actually care about that
we do care about though the fact that in
this example I guess if we scale down a
couple of instances and uswest one a we
don't want it to automatically just
start killing random instances in us
we're see and and start up new ones at a
just to maintain that perfect balance if
we're halfway through a computer job for
example we might be halfway through it
twenty or thirty minute job and we
really don't want it to start killing
random instances that are halfway
through those jobs just so that we can
have perfect balance so the other option
that you have available a zonal managed
instance groups and in a zone all
management since group it is only
scaling independently within a single
zone so we can create one instance group
for each zone and we don't need to worry
about perfectly balancing these workers
another challenge that we have here is
that these instance groups are limited
to running a thousand instances per
group and so if you talk to Google it's
it's possible to increase this limit a
little bit but not sufficient to run the
tens of thousands of instances that we
want so the way we solved this is by
implementing shadowed management since
groups basically in each zone we
create more than one management in this
group and that allows us to scale above
a thousand workers in a single zone
this doesn't make order scaling a bit
more challenging I'm gonna talk a bit
more about what a scale like in a second
each of these managed instance groups
creates an instance from a single
template so if you want to run different
types of workers like CPU and GPU
workers you need to create more than one
instance group acroos we also have
different types of different size
instances for each one of these so on
our CPU workers some jobs only need a
few cause and some jobs can take
advantage of 96 core machines likewise
some of our GPU jobs only you need one
GPU others can take advantage of
multiple GPUs and we obviously want to
optimize the cost by not running
workloads on machines that are over
provisioned for that job so bringing
this back to our diagram we now have
multiple availability zones in the
region each of the availability zones
has multiple instance types and then
each of these instance types has
multiple management's and it's groups
within it so at this point we're
starting to get quite a few management
since groups up here but there's one
more thing that we need to consider and
the final picture of the piece of the
puzzle is which region to select for the
workload so it's a little bit it's
actually a map of the world believe it
or not and if you're thinking about
where to run your computer workloads
there's several factors that you need to
consider so you know obviously think
about legal considerations if there's
things like data privacy and where your
data is being stored and processed
latency requirements of your jobs need
to talk to data talk to each other or
talk to data in a different region you
want to co-locate your data in your
computer so you don't want all of your
data stored in u.s. West and then you
compute happening in US east and finally
not all regions are created equal so if
you're doing things like this running
thousands of GPUs you really want to
talk with your tam or solutions
architect and get a sense of which
region is going to best support those
workloads in our case the answer was
multiple regions so generally when
people are running in multiple regions
they're doing this again for high
availability reasons but in our case we
care more about having the flexibility
that we can run our workloads in
whichever region is easiest to get
capacity so we have pretty spiky
workloads during the day
sometimes an engineer will kick off a
job and we might need you know thousands
or more servers and being able to create
that in any region gives us great
flexibility to be able to take advantage
of quarters and multiple regions running
in multiple regions of course isn't free
so there's additional cost and
complexity with setting this up you need
to think about latency for example if
you were running machine learning
training you would not want your workers
talking across regions because it's
going to be quite a lot of extra latency
but for simulation workloads they're all
running pretty independently so that
wasn't a problem for us
you do need to think carefully about
where your data is located as I
mentioned you don't want your data
stored and West and your computer
happening in East so Google Cloud
Storage has this great feature called
called multi regional multi-regional
buckets and when you create a multi
regional bucket you choose a continent
like the US and then it automatically
replicates your data across the
different regions in that continent so
when you use a Modi regional bucket you
pay slightly more for the storage but
then it makes transfer within all of
those regions free and fast so bringing
this back to our little diagram we have
at the top some multi regional buckets
so we're using cloud storage and
container registry for storing our data
we then have multiple regions each one
of these regions has multiple
availability zones each one of these
availability zones has multiple worker
types and each one of these worker types
has multiple instance groups associated
with it so we really end up with a huge
number you know you can see how it's
easy to end up with dozens of management
since groups doing this to manage all of
this we're huge fans of terraform so
terraform allows us to easily define the
infrastructure as code and we can easily
make updates and rollout changes to this
and terraform modules are a really great
way to build something like this because
we can set up a template for this is
what a particular instance group should
look like and then you can use that to
compose what a zone should look like and
you can use that to compose what a
region should look like and you can sort
of template and parameterize each one of
those modules when we run this many
instance groups we need to think
carefully about how and where we are
scaling so a typical workday accrues
starts with engineers submitting jobs in
the early morning it ramps up during the
day you notice it's a bit of a la
level there over the lunch period and
then it tapers off a bit towards
midnight and we have some some low
priority jobs which can run overnight
but the majority of our engineers
getting their work done during the day
and we don't want engineers wedding on
machines if we can all avoid it so
scaling like this is always a balance
between two things you have queue times
and utilization on the one hand if we
were to scale up too quickly or if we
were to scaled down too slowly then we
would end up with excess capacity and
this would mean our utilization would be
low with the paying for servers that we
don't need on the other hand if we were
scale up too slowly or we scaled down
too quickly then we end up with jobs
queuing and that's not ideal either
because now we're paying for engineers
who are waiting for these jobs to finish
so we need to be able to handle record
changes in demand but we also need to
ensure that we're closely matching this
demand curve and that we're not over or
under provisioning the number of servers
we need we have some unique aspects to
managing this auto scaling at crews so
we need to balance the scaling across
multiple regions and zones and instance
groups in some cases we want to scale we
want to prefer scaling in us in one
region and only sort of start scaling up
in another region if we can't get
capacity there we have different queues
with different priorities so if we have
a low priority job we might not want to
scale up at all like we're just happy
for it to kind of sit there in queue and
when you also need to avoid interrupting
long running tasks when we're scaling
down and the default autoscaler that
that comes with GCP can target something
like a stack drive a metric so you can
target something like CPU use or you can
target your own custom metric like queue
length but unfortunately when the
default autoscaler scales down it always
picks a random instance to terminate and
when it does that it only gives you 60
seconds notice that this incident is
instance is going to scale down as I
mentioned earlier if we're halfway
through a 20 or 30 minute simulation job
we really don't want to kill that
instance just because it got unlucky so
to meet these needs we built our own
auto scalar and I highly recommend this
if you're not if the if the stock
autoscaler is not working for you it's
actually pretty easy to build with just
a few GC p components so we have here a
cloud scheduler which kicks off a cloud
function every minute or so and that
cloud
it's just a few hundred lines of
JavaScript so the cloud function is
doing a couple of things it reaches out
to stackdriver and at us first of all
for the demand so how many jobs do we
have running in progress and how many
jobs do we currently have queued and
then it looks at the supply side of
things how many workers do we currently
have connected or that are currently
scaling out if it decides that we need
to scale up additional capacity it can
do this really simply by just reaching
out to the instance group manager API
there and it can just say please hit the
target size for this instance group 2x
if it wants to scale down it puts a
message on the pub sub Q and then
whenever a worker is idle it simply
checks this queue to see if there's a
shutdown message for that particular
worker class and the unlucky worker that
drew the short straw just e registers
itself from the instance group manager
and then it terminates gracefully so
this architecture allows us to ensure
there were any other terminating workers
that are idle another thing that we
needed to consider when running this
many instances is the networking so we
ran all of our instances and a private
end of PPC unless users private IP
addresses and when you're using private
ip's it means that if you need to reach
the outside Internet then you need to go
through an app google has a product
called cloud net which went GA back in
November but when we set this up cloud
net was not available so we actually had
to manually create a whole bunch of Nats
and that meant we needed to create a net
and every availability zone basically in
every region and some availability zones
needed more than one net to handle the
bandwidth throughput that we needed and
this works but it's do infrastructure
that we don't want to manage so we're
currently in the process of migrating to
cloud net and cloud net can
automatically scale horizontally to
support your demand also if you're doing
any communication with private with with
managed Google services you have to
enable private Google access so private
Google access allows your machines that
are running on private IP addresses to
route directly to those services like
bigquery or GCS or spanner allows you to
route directly to those services without
needing to go through your net so it
significantly reduces the bottleneck on
your net private Google access is
actually pretty complicated to set up if
you're using if you're managing your
instances but if you're using cloud net
it's it's a checkbox when you set up
your V PC so check that box and you will
live a happy life the final picture of
the the final piece of the picture here
is storage so as I mentioned we're using
Google Cloud Storage for storing inputs
and output data and we're using Google
container registry to store our runtime
container images and Google Cloud
Storage we have things like application
binaries map tiles machine learning
models and sensor data all of these
things that we need to run a simulation
we've gotten pretty amazing throughput
from GCS so this is our right throughput
in a typical day we might be peeking it
sort of a gigabyte per second but we
don't write nearly as much data as we
read so this is our read throughput and
you can see on a typical day
we're peeking it over 380 gigabytes per
second of data so that's over 3 terabyte
and this is an example of where the
cloud is super powerful because if we
won't if we set out to build
infrastructure like this ourselves it
would be incredibly challenging to
manage reliably at that scale and it
would also not be value-add work for a
cruise instead we simply click a button
in the console or write a few lines of
terraform and we have this kind of
capacity available to us instantly we
have a bunch of work coming down the
pipeline for Hydra so we're always
making performance improvements to
handle the increasing load we're looking
at tasks pipelining so that we can
prefetch assets for the next job that
we're about to run before we've finished
the current job well we're optimizing
where we where we send jobs based on
which workers already have resources
cached and we're a be testing our worker
updates so that we can make sure that
make sure that workers are working
successfully and then we haven't
introduced any regressions and our work
infrastructure before we start managing
production load so the last thing I'm
going to talk about is our data
analytics pipeline if you recall from
this previous slide I mentioned that
we're storing an output data in and
Google Cloud storage and then we ingest
this into bigquery and like with Hydra I
think it's helpful to touch briefly on
the architecture of where we came from
before I talk about how we're using
bigquery so in this diagram you can see
our simulation job scheduler that's
Hydra and Hydra is pulling work from the
facts and from other simulation data
that we need and then the output data
that it produces this goes into our
graph compute engine and the graph
computer engine allows engineers to run
post-processing tasks like they might
want to for example compare that output
data against human labelled ground truth
data and create aggregations on that to
score how well we did in that simulation
the post-processing data was then stored
as ever if I was an s3 and we chose ever
here for a couple reasons first of all
it was just really easy to work with
Hydra already had the ability to save
output files and a s3 and secondly we
didn't need to worry about schemas so
our engineers could make changes to the
AV code or they can make changes to
their post-processing steps and that
data would get written directly to every
files which they were then able to
access without needing to go through any
team or get approval to change their
schemas we had to lake we have tools
like jupiter notebooks and also custom
analysis tooling which can could
directly read these ever files and then
render them to create sorts of
dashboards but this architecture became
pretty limiting once we started wanting
to run more advanced analysis without a
proper query engine here we couldn't
answer advanced queries without going
back and editing those post-processing
code and this also created pretty
significant memory use front-end
visualization tools needed to read these
ever files and it did not scale well as
the number of simulations increased
finally it's pretty time consuming
building this type of tolling if you're
tying it specifically to the data format
that you're using there's many different
ways we could have gone about solving
this but given that we were using Google
Cloud we decided to use bigquery as the
data warehouse so we have an ETL
pipeline here that's a simple ingestion
service and that's taking the data
produced by our post-processing graph
compute engine and ingest this into
bigquery we've had great success with
bigquery so far so we're ingesting over
10 terabytes a day of data with no
administration overhead to us we can get
this data into bigquery within minutes
of finishing a simulation and we can
query it within seconds and the bigquery
sequel interface is accessible and
supported by many different reporting
tools not just our in-house ones now
engineers can access this data via the
bigquery console and UI we also have
things like Jupiter node
and bi toes like looker in tableau they
can access it and we also have our own
custom front-end analysis tooling so the
last thing I'm going to talk about today
is a bit about this this this custom
analysis tooling that we build
I'll give you an insight into the world
of self-driving car development so I'm
gonna walk through a complete example of
a simulation and how we run that and how
we understand the results so here bear
with me here we have a car trying to
make an unprotected left turn and the
car needs to yield to these cars in the
oncoming lane of traffic so this is
represented in pink we also have what we
call a region of interest which is the
dotted line that you see and alkyne
needs to clear this region of interest
between that gap and traffic between
those two cars what we're interested in
this particular example is which gap our
card chose to go through and what the
the gap size was what were the period of
time was and the gap size is the period
of time between when car 1 the blue car
has left that region of interest and
when car two the green car entered that
region of interest okay so if you're
still with me keep that in mind we move
on to the next slide this is an example
of some of the custom visualization
tooling that we built so you're in what
we're looking at the gap size between
the two cars as we're making an
unprotected left turn and in this
particular example we're comparing two
factors we're looking at how the speed
of those oncoming cars and the distance
between those oncoming cars affects the
gap that we chose and the size of that
gap and you can see here that we're
comparing a base branch and a feature
branch and then in the third box you can
see the Delta between the base and
feature branch so engineers can easily
identify with this particular commit how
that impacted which gap we chose as a
function of these two input parameters
each one of these green squares here is
actually a separate individual
simulation so that's running on hydro
and that's generating probably a
gigabyte of output data each so you can
see how we end up with these large-scale
computer and data storage challenges
once we start running these types of
simulations another thing about this
tool is that the engineers can actually
click on one of these particular squares
and it gives them more information about
that particular run so we have a lot of
ongoing work in this in the simulation
tooling like this
we're closely with our AV engineering
teams to understand what type of
experiments they want to run and how we
can best sort of understand and
visualize those experiments so thank you
for joining today before I go I want to
leave you with three thoughts so the
first one simulation for self-driving
cars is a super interesting problem it's
a privilege to get to work on it at
cruise we're using the latest tools and
infrastructure to build to test these
cars at massive scale so this includes
things like Google cloud and also
in-house develop software and finally it
takes a diverse range of skill sets to
build self-driving cars so you know we
have not just machine learning engineers
and robotics engineers but back in
engineers infrastructure engineers 3d
front-end engineers data data science
and we're hiring in San Francisco in
Seattle if you're interested in working
on these types of problems every day so
[Music]